I don't think there's any question that
short-termism of flakes decision makers
both in government and business and one
of the things that I am really
encouraged by as the discussions that
we're having here at the iop about what
to do to change that dynamic to make
sure that all of us can get behind sort
of a long-term vision of what we want
this country to be what we want our
economy to look like and both our
businesses and families can enjoy the
benefit the reform conservative movement
is promised on a one very important idea
and that is that conservative philosophy
and and its policies can best effect a
positive and for the people of this
country and I think if one is a
conservative the way to go about
achieving conservative ends is to better
the situation of people whether that's
the working middle class or whether
that's the young the old and I think
we're going to see a lot of discussion
around the 2016 presidential race that
stems from the the thought leaders in
the reform conservative movement
you know I think that our country has
lived with tolerated enjoyed politics
since its inception politics really is
about the exchange of ideas and the
communication of people's views both
long-term and short-term and I think in
the end where politics will lead us is
as much about the leadership qualities
of the politicians than anything else